looking at your imdb it shows that you
are like you said kind of this one man
band so you writer director producer
editor cinematographer visual effects
camera
looking back
do you wish you had spent more time just
kind of focused on being a writer or was
that a natural evolution that you needed
to find what you really loved the actual
activity of
most of that and again this is
i i have an interesting sort of like
parable that i do feel like relates to
that
um
so everyone bear with me for a second
so when i
when i graduated uh sc i did a like i
did like a big thesis film and like i
raised money and i like i tried to like
do a big sort of like coming out
sort of party um
it failed abysmally like
it's fine but it literally led to like
nothing like no opportunities i owed
like a bunch of money
um
and basically
like i had two choices then which was
well i
i can't make any i can't i can't ask
anyone for any more favors i can't ask
anyone for more money
so
either
um
i don't make anything anymore or i start
taking it upon myself to teach myself
all these sort of like trades at least
in a way to be competent at them
um
so i can keep making things
um and so that's basically where that
all came from was
i wanted to keep making stuff because i
said oh this thing that i'd like i tried
a big shot at like collapsed
i like it but again it did not do
anything from a professional career
perspective um
but i want to keep having chances and i
want to keep trying so i'm going to have
to do this i'm going to have to
practice like you know cinematography
and i'm going to have to become like an
editor and i'm going to have to do all
these things
um
otherwise i just kind of like i'm not
going to be able to keep making things
and that really sort of interestingly
led me down the direction of
youtube and digital because then i could
one man band like shows or pilots
and that i made a pilot for a series
um that i thought was really awesome and
i got pitched to and i basically i did
everything myself i got pitched to a
really big digital company at the time
called maker studios um and
the
executive who hired me
was like i don't know what to do with
this particular show but would you come
on and do this for another show here
and the other thing about myself is
anytime i've been struggling
um like financially
like it's difficult to pay the rent or
i'm uh
i'm too
like my day job is too sort of like
engrossing like that i can't focus on my
own sort of creative pursuits
um
i knew fairly early on that i i needed
to find a very specific sort of
situation that allowed for enough
stability but also enough freedom that i
could keep pursuing um the things that i
was passionate about and so in this very
weird roundabout way
teaching myself to one-man band
a digital series then led to my
employment doing that so that then i had
enough sort of like um
freedom and mental space that i could
come home
and i could write or i could write on
the weekend and i wasn't
like because previous to that like i'm
doing like all sorts of just really like
odd
odd jobs and random things
um but that i couldn't concentrate
because i was too stressed
um
and so yes so basically in this very
weird way
teaching myself all those
crafts
and then being able to apply them on
digital shows allowed me the freedom to
keep writing
so again it's a very sort of roundabout
uh
way that that worked for me
but i forget exactly what my thesis is
but it was probably something along the
lines of like
figure out what works for you and
understand that it's it's never going
it's never probably going to be the sort
of uh
the paint by numbers situation
i guess
can we go back to the party in the in
the film
i guess so you you did this thesis film
at sc and then you threw sort of an
event like a screening or oh i i i meant
coming out party like in the debutante
way but yes i did have like i did have a
screening um sorry go ahead oh no but
i'd love to hear more about it just
because i'm just curious
what was the goal you were hoping that
maybe prospective employers
would would find out in in and you would
then land a job
yeah well that's the other that is a
little bit of the other problem right is
i think that when you're young you can
even have talent and you can have
ambition and you can have
all sorts of positive qualities but you
also don't really know how the whole
system works real well
um
and i think that like now friend like i
have a um
i've been gearing up like other sort of
like uh independent projects right like
to do with like you know producers i
know or
talent and that sort of thing
um
and a lot of people i know have been
sort of like putting uh pressure on me
for a long time to do something like
that again
um
and my thought has always been
not
not until i feel like the dominoes are
set up correctly
and i'm going to be a little bit more
risk adverse
than in that uh way than other people
but like but to me that's also what i
kind of learned from doing it like when
i was young and going like well i again
time energy
money
like and i didn't really know
what happened after that i'm sure i had
like vague notions of like someone will
like give me an opportunity excuse me um
but you have to be a lot more specific
you know you have to have like a
strategy and a plan if you're going to
go down that
uh route
and so again
to me
it's important to fail because that's
how you learn
um
and then hopefully you can take those
lessons and then you can apply them
later on in a situation where you go
like okay now i have a much better sense
about how this is all supposed to go
down to give me the
best chance
at being successful or letting giving
this project the best chance to be
successful
was it really a failure or
just that you had such high expectations
for it i do think that again for
something to be the most successful
version of itself it's obviously
fulfilling goals that you hoped it
fulfilled and in this case that movie
did not fulfill
said goals
um
but
again from the point of view of just
having the experience and doing it and
learning everything you do like through
that that is also invaluable
um
obviously like that it's a very sort of
like trite cliche thing to like sort of
say but like you like you do need to
learn by doing
um especially in this sort of situation
i do think
that however you can mitigate your risk
like the most that you can because again
in this world mistakes are expensive
usually
not always but like but they
even even small projects like you know
you lose like money when they don't like
uh
do whatever you were expecting them to
do
again i think that it's very important
to try to create a like scenario in
which you can keep trying
i feel like
i feel like if i had ever been in a
situation in which my one
my one shot
failed
then i
i'm sure i would have never had any
opportunity to achieve any sort of like
level of success whatever that means
because it takes
a lot of tries
um and it takes a lot of failures and so
then i think the question really is for
any individual
how do i create a scenario in which i'm
allowed to do that because that is hard
right
like
for me i've always been very lucky
because
i have a lot of friends
who are very talented actors and because
they were talented actors and we have a
very good relationship
and they trust me to do what i do
um that then they would always be
willing to put their money
into projects so we could keep doing
stuff together
you know
um
or again
like
i would also then at the same time be
going
literally on youtube and what like
watching video co-pilot i don't even
know if video co-pilot's still around
they they probably are there's something
like it um
and like learning how to do like special
effects and
learning how to again
how to be a better like
again i'm not a great dp by any means
but at least competent
um
because that's available to you
and then
again whatever situation allows you to
keep taking
chances
because it's a it's a batting average
thing you know if you're only up at bat
once yeah maybe you hit it but you're
probably not going to you're that's just
the reality
so it's how do you
how do you like figure out how to keep
having chances at bat however like
whatever that means to you i guess and
once you realized this was quote unquote
a failure in your eyes maybe not to
other people
what did you then start doing to say
okay well maybe it wasn't my one shot
and now i have to try it another way
i think that that to me
um
one thing
that
that experience taught me was to be a
lot more
interest
i'll be a lot more interested in this
sort of idea of film as a business
um
and this idea like because my my thesis
was was very wacky right it was just
it's
very odd
like
it did not fit neatly into any box and i
think that that was there was a couple
sort of issues and i think that was one
issue because it was sort of like well
this is probably too strange
like for
like
the for the industry like uh
for the average person like looking to
do business with you
where does this go it did not neatly fit
into any sort of like box
um
and again there are individuals who like
come out of the gate with something like
really unique and avant-garde and
pushing the boundary and all sorts of
these things and and they are rewarded
for it it's it's important for everyone
to sort of realize that that's not
everyone
like
there is like
obviously everyone wants things that are
new and exciting and they want the new
like and everyone wants to know what the
new cool flavor is and what is like
gonna get people like excited to go see
this movie um
but there is this very real business
aspect to it that if you sort of ignore
that
you kind of do that at your own like
peril
um
and i think the other thing that i
thought
going into it was
you do something like a short for an
opportunity
just to be hired to do something and
again i do that does happen
um
but i do think that if i were to do it
again i would have been a lot more sort
of specific about like you know things
that seem obvious now where it's like
you do a short
that is from a feature that you've also
already written and that feature is
marketable
right
like
or
like that sort of idea like what are the
very specific concrete steps
that this
uh
that this project is a part of
again trying to feed into the idea of
it's an industry and a business versus
looking at it as like someone wanting to
say oh you're
we're just gonna pick you out because
you're so talented
um
and again that does happen for people
but it doesn't happen for everyone and
then the question ultimately becomes
okay if that didn't happen for me
then like
what can i do
to keep sort of like trying
you